[Music]
do you guys
judge the people in your lives by the
way that they drive absolutely
uh yeah bart quan is the worst driver
i've ever seen
well what do you mean judge like oh he's
driving terribly so he's a terrible
yep they're driving a bad guy
or judge their driving skills oh yeah
it's more surface time yeah but
there's a survey of 2 000 drivers who
found
that 78 agreed that the way a person
drives says a lot about their
personality oh i think everything
everyone does says a lot about the
person true
no matter what it is having just driven
to vegas there's so many people who
drive
trucks who just get up on people's asses
like you [ __ ] move your [ __ ]
[ __ ] like you let it go faster
what does that say about that person
they're [ __ ] you know what i think
it is
analyzing it might for like with my own
experience bias experience is that i
feel like those
people that ride people's asses when
they're driving
is because when they're behind the wheel
they feel a sense of
power that they don't normally feel in
their day-to-day life so they have to
assert that power on the road because
they feel protected
by all the metal and then they could
just like speed off or whatever and i
think that's why the aggressive drivers
tend to be [ __ ] because they just
don't have control in their own lives
they're pricks over here but i'm telling
you because
i think like analyzing my own driving
habits oh [ __ ]
[Music]
are you like very aggressively hold on
i'm not i'm not like a mega aggressive
[ __ ] yeah yeah
but i think she has autopilot huh yeah
oh my god for sure oh my god you don't
even know how much i use it
but do i want it now no i mean it's
safer that's why
okay i i don't give a hundred percent
power to it either
anyway so the reason why um
i'm saying all this is because if i
analyze like how my driving habits have
changed over time as i've grown and
matured
i think i'm a much nicer driver
and i think it comes from a place of
like like
sense of like needing control when
you're behind the wheel or whatever
because when i was a lot younger too
i absolutely hated being behind the
wheel or like in a car i just [ __ ]
hated being a car
a lot of like traumatic childhood [ __ ]
in cars or whatever and i'm just like
get me to my destination i want
to get the [ __ ] out of the car but then
like the more i
analyze my past and i break things down
and like i don't hold it on so much deep
within me and i'm like
like carrying it anymore i have noticed
my own driving habits have changed so
that's why i'm like i feel like that's
where that's coming from
that makes sense little guys yeah you
know
interesting are you calling yourself a
prick then i think i wasn't
i was a quick driver before i think i
was like i wouldn't let people get in
front of me i'm like
nah this is my spot and like yeah like
it's just like [ __ ] moves
steve's like called it you know what i'm
saying
yep how good was that yeah i would just
say i was i'm probably like impatient
because i do i do have some road rage
especially when there's like traffic
she does i do i do i do i do i do too
yeah and like but she does i hate it
i especially hate it when cars merge
into your lane without signaling because
i was like
what benefit what benefit does that give
you you're not letting me know and then
if i hit you it's going to be my [ __ ]
fault i was like
[ __ ] no yeah true that's a nice thing
about driving a taller car because i'm
like
i win in all situations
i'm not even mad i'm just like oh if you
did that any closer
i'd win this fight yeah okay so they
were saying that more than half of
american drivers would not date someone
they thought was an unsafe driver yeah
but i mean that makes sense
how insane define it yeah they would
have to be pretty unsafe yeah
nikki is a hell writer bro but i love
her so much
and she gets me where i'm going and
never seen you get an accident either so
i'm like it works
it was crazy nearly a fifth of those
polled
said that they have ended a relationship
with the partner
due to their driving really that often
we're driving too
crazy or too slowly whatever the reasons
are because of driving yeah
that's crazy yeah because of driving
i just imagine because like they maybe
it shows like their level of
like uh aggression and you're like okay
i don't know if i want this level of
aggression around me because it's like
if you're like getting road rage to the
point where you're like hopping out the
car to like go fight somebody else
that's scary yeah that's a deal breaker
you're not feeling out your window but
yeah you're straight
even though you've been yelling out your
window like i feel like there's certain
levels to it
hey don't worry baby we're just going to
[ __ ] with them a little bit
no that is scary put this [ __ ] ski
mask on real quick
also 46 said that drivers who followed
the rules of the road are more
trustworthy that's how they felt about
drivers yeah
they're more trustworthy i wouldn't
agree with that but
yeah i don't know about that but the
yeah the road rage part i can see like
being a problem if you're like oh this
guy's got angry issues
definitely i especially hate the cars
that like when you're trying to merge
into a lane and they see you merging in
and they just speed up yeah it's w
those are the worst bmws i used to be
one of those
i'm telling you but i'm just saying like
but why though like you got so much
space there's like so much space in the
awesome you just speed up because
someone wants to i don't know
i'll do that if there's traffic okay
i'll do that with this truck it's not
personal bmw drivers what the [ __ ]
true i mean we're all sharing the same
space here the road
we all we're all trying to get somewhere
so just you know what i [ __ ] hate
people that can't [ __ ] zipper like
getting oh yeah
getting it like when you're merging and
then oh the car has a space what did you
just call me
yeah zipper
yeah you know when you like have a car
and then there's a space and you're
merging
in and another person goes in behind
that car and that car goes behind that
car
and it's just real simple but then some
people like no i have to be in this
space
up here in front of this guy i'm like
nah dude i will block a car
i've done this before and i will i might
still do it now um
only if like you know how like the a car
will go into the side when
you're so submerged already yeah and try
to pass as many cars as they can before
getting in i'm like
yeah if i'm already halfway merged i'll
just stop merging i'm like this is a
good place to wait
yeah yeah yeah if you can do that with
all your privilege i have a mini cooper
we can't i can't possibly handle that
much width
[Laughter]
dude that's true because then when i see
those guys and then they're coming in or
whatever and it's like merging
but then like this other [ __ ] we were
like over here he's trying to like cut
then in that merge there's like a good
chunk of space and i'll stop in like in
the middle and i'm like
you're gonna be behind me [ __ ]
but yeah i don't know
see i used to be such an angry driver
you know years ago i was uh
circling nikki's place to like literally
i was there to [ __ ]
you yeah and somebody uh
tweeted me and they're like hey i just
saw you
pull an unsafe traffic maneuvers what
well all i did was turn left and like i
think they
were come on coming and i turned left
just after them like it wasn't even the
big deal
but they're like i saw you steve green
yeah that's creepy and you're mini
cooper like they knew all that
[ __ ] with your license plate yeah right
no way
and it was one of those things where i'm
like what are you gonna do i didn't do
anything wrong what are you gonna do
yeah what are you gonna do since then
did you get more paranoid about who can
see
[ __ ] no i was just like what the [ __ ] i
already tell people in a mini cooper
how many tall guys are in mini coopers
like it's not gonna be hard
true there's also like bright color too
yeah you're
you'll find me don't worry i have to
have to say like
finding out that you drove a mini cooper
was uh stood out to me
right yeah you don't seem like a kind of
good way or a bad way ah sounds like
that twisting
okay i don't know if that's not always
good okay he's like i used to look at
you as a man
i saw i respected you i think it is an
interesting thing and i wouldn't say
it's bad work but i appreciate the
juxtaposition of it right yeah all of
you need to drive it
down and i'm down too i'll bring it next
time i didn't bring it today
but it's so [ __ ] fun to drive
especially in sport
mode oh you guys will have fun it's so
fun
it's like driving a golf cart oh fun
golf carts are really that's pretty fun
so back i use the code steve green when
you check out
the mini cooper store
okay so back to this so then they're
saying that three out of four
they characterized drivers who don't
wear seat belts as
reckless yeah duh
yeah no i would look at them as insane
because how can you put up with that
beeping sound
exactly it's so long crazy yeah i can't
do it no but i've actually seen people
like
like in the 90s like or not in the night
like 2000s when the beeping started
yeah they i've seen people like put like
just click the seat belt and then sit in
front of it
like the only reason why that doesn't
make any sense is like you've already
put in the effort yeah but they just
want to do it that one time so it could
shut up
just can i say this real quick and i
love ralph nader by the way thank you
ralph nader for everything you did for
seat belts
and safety but when i get into a car and
i'm moving
and i got a bunch of [ __ ] books next
to me in the past
and i gotta [ __ ] put the seatbelt
like
in the place and then beeps anyway i'm
like [ __ ] sakes ralph nader why'd you
[ __ ] me
what exactly did ralph manner do roth
nader is why we have seat belts like
in the mid 70s he like he's why we have
all these safety standards and all this
stuff because all the big cars were like
[ __ ] you
we don't care if people are getting
slice and dice with the dashboards and
[ __ ]
yeah like yeah it was like that and
ralph nader's like they should have a
seat belt in every car
yeah yeah [ __ ] ralph nader right oh no
i'm saving all those children only when
i'm moving only when i'm moving
you know what some people have is they
actually have like a seatbelt clip like
without the seatbelt attached to it that
you'll then throw it in the thing yeah
but always have it my mechanic friends
have that but it's because they're like
testing cars and stuff so they don't
like want to put the seat belt on if
they're just like backing it up or
something like that so they throw the
little key in
but i've seen other people that have
that i'm like but why
yeah just protect yourself you idiot oh
anyway
and then 36 percent have said that they
have refused to be driven by a friend
due to their poor driving habits that's
fair totally fair i have intentionally
avoided driving in certain cars for
certain people with
actually no and julia probably i should
but no
you're a bad driver julia oh i'm so
sorry hey i mean
i am what i am so who's the bad driver
who's the bad driver
well do you feel this energy
through your seat okay uh i'm not a bad
driver joe's a bad driver
yeah oh joe joe is a bit reckless
but not as overt as bart does he drive
like he moves through life
exactly he's gotten better though oh has
he i think so
you know what you're right because
recently i did right in his car and it
wasn't that bad but the reason like
wedding what's ingrained in my
my memory is he dr he has a heavy foot
and the heaviest yeah and so he'll like
break really hard like speed really hard
i'm like
god damn i'm a throw off yeah that's how
i felt
uh when david had his tesla oh he also
yeah well it's because of regenerative
braking i know i have that [ __ ] in my
cartoon
yeah he'll drive my car and i'm getting
nauseous but then i'm driving my car and
then he'll get nauseous so i'm like
yeah elon fix that what the [ __ ] is that
can you set the level of the breaking
regenerative
like level but you could turn it on or
turn it off when was this though
because all that tells me with all due
respect is that you haven't ridden with
bart as recently
oh i mean art's pretty scary i guess i
got used to
bart's bart makes your soul jump out of
your body while he's driving
and then your soul just like snaps back
and you're like oh god
and then he drives forward again your
soul's out of your body again true
bart's the kind of driver when you get
in the car you're like
do i want to die do i do i want to have
a conversation with him and die or
should i just stay silent and just have
him focus on the road
well for me with you it's do we should
we get to our destination on time
and have a conversation or not have a
conversation or have to reroute a
thousand times because you miss every
single legs and every turn because
you're having a conversation because i'm
trying to i'm trying to respect the
conversation i'm trying to be
fully present that's what i'm preaching
about casey because it's like even
though we have a destination to go to
and like 100 miles an hour whether
there's a time limit or not
he gets so like involved into the
conversation he's so
curious about like learning more about
whoever he's talking to
or the conversation yeah like literally
like even though like the minimum speed
on a freeway is 65 he's going like 40 or
oh my god and then like you'll miss an
exit and i'm like
that's it no we're talking for the rest
of the ride you have to focus
you know cease of conversation just for
me the first time
i heard you say that i was like that's
very interesting no conversation in the
car from ksc
and then when i witnessed it i was like
oh we missed things the white man's nose
the wife knows the same thing happened
to me in the car with casey but i was
like hey man why is your dashboard all
[ __ ] up and you're like
i get mad sometimes i'm like
so i have my radio it's like
it's just cracked down the center it's
[ __ ] up
somebody else that did that i'm involved
with that
oh yeah oh you punched the tour that was
one of those conversations that should
have
ceased yes but we didn't no no no i'm
saying because we argued so i was
involved i know i know i'm just like i
should have punched i just think it's
funny if you're both really collectively
like [ __ ] on his car
radio
[Laughter]
ryan is a as a pretty safe driver he
gets
road rage only when like other people
are driving like irresponsibly and he
only gets angry because there's other
people in the car and he worries about
their safety
the people's safety in danger to get
revenge on the one that no no no you're
who puts us in danger jesus that's cute
how do you live that down
i'm just good job boo
[Music]
you